au pied de cet immeuble d'un quartier
populaire de caracas
ce petit magasin est une véritable oasis
beurre huile café champeau dentifrice
des produits de base mais difficilement
accessible le venezuela est toujours
confiné les magasins non essentiels
fermé et un seulement par famille est
autorisé à sortir de son domicile pour
se rendre au supermarché ou dans les
pharmacies
ici comme le commerce est à l'intérieur
du quartier les gens plus de facilités
pour sortir au moment ils peuvent
acheter leurs produits et bien sûr les
prix sont bas parce qu'on essaie en
vivant ici de trouver les meilleurs prix
afin d'aider la communauté la
distribution mensuelle de produits
alimentaires introduite en 2016 par le
président maduro pour faire face aux
pénuries a été mise à mal par les effets
conjugués de la pandémie et des
sanctions internationales
au total ce sont plus de 6 millions de
vénézuéliens qui en bénéficient avec le
blocus la pandémie vous n'obtenez pas
les produits la plupart des produits
distribués par le gouvernement ont été
importés le peuple s'est donc organisé
en créant ses boutiques ses kiosques sur
un pâté de maison là où il y avait un
magasin il y en a maintenant 5 5 petites
boutiques avec toutes sortes de produits
il y a deux semaines à l'issue d'une
visite d'une dizaine de jours au
venezuela
l'envoyé de l'onu a déclaré dans son
rapport préliminaire que les sanctions
des états unis et de l'union européenne
contre le peslier aggravé la crise
humanitaire à l'ena douanes demande à
washington la levée des mesures
coercitives unilatérales aux effets
dévastateurs sur la santé l'éducation et
l'alimentation de la population que des
éoliennes